Esta era la ciencia de servicio al público.
Para esto vine a la universidad
y así es como preferiría pasar mi vida.
Y así esta coalición...
esta improbable coalición de ciudadanos, pastores, periodistas y científicos,
se reunieron para descubrir la verdad utilizando ciencia, defensa y activismo.
Un pediatra local descubrió
que los casos de envenenamiento por plomo en la infancia se habían duplicado
en Flint durante la crisis.
Y el estado de Michigan se vio obligado a reconocer el problema
y tomar medidas para corregirlo.
Este grupo y muchos otros protegieron a los niños de Flint.
Algunos meses después,
el presidente Obama intervino y declaró una emergencia federal,
y ahora Flint recibe más de USD 600 millones
para salud, nutrición, educación
y revisión de su infraestructura de agua.
Sin embargo, la arrogancia y la indiferencia insensible por la salud pública
demostrado por científicos e ingenieros en estas agencias gubernamentales
va más allá de lo increíble.
Estas culturas poco saludables que están pudriendo estos grupos,
donde el foco está en cumplir regulaciones y cajas de verificación
en contraposición a la protección de la salud pública,
son simplemente espantosas.
Simplemente vean este correo electrónico que escribió una empleada de la EPA,
donde se lee:
"No estoy tan segura de que queramos arriesgarnos por la comunidad de Flint".
La deshumanización de toda una población no podría ser más obvia.
Ahora, comparen eso con el primer canon de la ingeniería,
que, en mi opinión, debe ser la primera ley de la humanidad:
"Mantener primordialmente la salud, la seguridad y el bienestar del público",
por encima de todo.
Este es el juramento hipocrático que rara vez hemos reconocido,
y mucho menos aplicado.
Y así cuando los científicos e ingenieros, muy parecido a los médicos,
hacen algo mal,
haciendo que personas se vean perjudicadas,
e incluso mueran,
si nuestros profesionales e incluso estudiantes no consiguen eso,
la sociedad paga un precio enorme.
Enterrado en la historia hay un personaje al que admiro profundamente,
un ingeniero llamado Peter Palchinsky.
Vivió en la época de la Unión Soviética.
Y Palchinsky se metió en problemas por su honestidad radical
y su voluntad de señalar los principales defectos
en el estúpido deseo de los soviéticos de una industrialización rápida.
Todos esperaban que siguiera órdenes procedentes de los superiores.
Cualquiera que hiciera preguntas o comentarios no era bienvenido.
Los soviéticos habían creado el mayor ejército de ingenieros del mundo.
Y, sin embargo, la mayoría eran meros engranajes
en una gigantesca máquina camino a la catástrofe.
Palchinsky, por otro lado, imploró a los ingenieros
que examinaran las consecuencias
económicas, políticas y sociales de sus acciones;
en otras palabras, que se centraran más en el público.
Su voz de la razón audaz fue vista como una amenaza
al establecimiento político,
y Joseph Stalin le hizo ejecutar en 1929.
La opinión de Palchinsky sobre los tecnócratas es muy diferente
a la de aquellos que sigue siendo muy popular y común,
el de un investigador sin pasión
que trabaja en su laboratorio en su torre de marfil,
o de un ingeniero nerd que trabaja en su cubículo.
Brillante, sin duda,
pero de alguna manera sin conexión con el mundo,
lo que muestra poca emoción,
como Spock de "Star Trek".
Este tipo.
(Risas)
Intentemos hacer el saludo de Spock.
No creo que tenga éxito...
Miren, no puedo ser Spock.
Gracias a Dios no puedo ser Spock.
(Risas)
Me acordé de esta distinción por un artículo reciente que salió
en una revista científica muy reputada,
que caracterizó nuestro trabajo de Flint como impulsado por un "idealismo juvenil",
y por "la sensibilidad dramática de Hollywood",
pidiendo a científicos que protejan sus fondos e instituciones de investigación
a toda costa, no importa la causa.
Y si piensan que tienen que involucrarse en algo,
incluso si es una emergencia,
traten de encontrar un grupo de activistas o una ONG,
y obtengan el apoyo total de la comunidad académica,
lo que quiera que esto signifique,
antes de involucrarse.
Ni una mención de nuestra moral y la obligación profesional
de prevenir el daño al público,
o el hecho de que tener toda esta experiencia,
recursos y, para algunos, incluso tenencia
para realizar esta tarea.
No estoy diciendo que cada científico deba ser un activista.
Hay consecuencias reales y a veces muy dolorosas al hablar.
Pero para denunciar esta idea, esta posibilidad
para poder proteger la financiación de la investigación,
simplemente gritos de cobardía egoísta,
y estos no son los ideales que queríamos dar a nuestros estudiantes.
Y Uds. pueden pensar: "Bien, todo esto suena genial,
pero nunca cambiará completamente las culturas organizativas,
o adoctrinar pensamientos en estudiantes y profesionales
para mirar su trabajo como bien público,
la ciencia al servicio del público.
Tal vez sea así.
Pero ¿una gran razón de eso podría ser
que no estamos entrenando a nuestros estudiantes correctamente?
Porque si miran de cerca,
nuestro sistema de educación hoy se centra más en la creación
lo que el exprofesor de Yale Bill Deresiewicz llama "oveja excelente",
jóvenes inteligentes y ambiciosos,
que sin embargo temen al riesgo, son tímidos, no tienen dirección
y, a veces, ensimismados.
Ahora, los niños... ya saben,
nos enamoramos de la ciencia cuando éramos niños,
y, sin embargo, pasamos la mayor parte del tiempo en la secundaria y universidad
simplemente saltando a través de aros
y haciendo cosas para pulir nuestro curriculum vitae
en lugar de sentarse
y reflexionar sobre lo que queremos hacer y qué queremos ser.
Y así,
los marcadores de empatía en nuestros graduados universitarios
han estado cayendo dramáticamente en las últimas dos décadas,
Mientras que las del narcisismo están en aumento.
También hay una creciente cultura de la desconexión
entre estudiantes de ingeniería y el público.
Estamos entrenados para construir puentes y resolver problemas complejos
pero no en cómo pensar o vivir o ser un ciudadano de este mundo.
Mis años de pregrado fueron la preparación explícita al trabajo,
y no puedo decir lo sofocante y doloroso que fue a veces.
Y así,
algunos piensan que la solución para grandes ingenieros y científicos,
es más formación técnica.
Tal vez sea así.
Pero ¿dónde están las discusiones sobre la toma de decisiones éticas
o de formar carácter,
o de discernir entre el bien del mal?
Miren este proyecto que amo y admiro profundamente.
Se llama "Proyecto de Imaginación Heroica".
Una idea original del Dr. Phil Zimbardo,
famoso por el experimento de la prisión de Stanford,
este programa busca entrenar a niños escolares de todo el mundo
a mirarse a sí mismos como héroes en estado latente,
o héroes en formación.
Así, estas mentes jóvenes trabajan para desarrollar habilidades y virtudes
para que cuando llegue la oportunidad,
no importa cuál sea esa oportunidad,
se pongan en pie y hagan lo correcto.
En otras palabras,
cualquier persona puede ser un héroe.
Piensen en esa idea por un segundo.
¿Por qué no enseñamos ciencia e ingeniería de esa manera
donde el heroísmo y el servicio público son vistos como valores clave?
Porque de hecho, a menudo es heroísmo
que no es solo el antídoto a la indiferencia pública,
sino también al mal sistemático como vimos en Flint.
Y así, sueño
lo que un científico o ingeniero del siglo XXI podría llegar a ser:
individuos motivados a dominar las ciencias
para servir a la sociedad,
y también para ser conscientes
del tremendo poder que tienen sus conocimientos y decisiones;
personas que están desarrollando su valor moral en todo momento,
y que se dan cuenta de que el conflicto y la controversia
no son necesariamente cosas malas
si nuestra lealtad final es para el público y el planeta.
Estas son las personas que se pondrán de pie como lo hicimos en Flint,
no siendo salvadores o héroes en los medios de comunicación,
sino altruistas y fundamentalmente buenos actores en los que poder confiar.
Imaginen fomentar esta mentalidad centrada en el público
en clase, en viajes de servicio y durante actividades
durante la universidad o incluso en la escuela secundaria,
para que estas jóvenes mentes se aferren a esos ideales
cuando realmente entren al mundo real,
ya sea en consultoría, en la academia, la formulación de políticas,
o incluso lleguen a ser presidentes de un país.
Algunos de los mayores desafíos de la humanidad se encuentran ante nosotros;
el agua potable contaminada es solo un ejemplo.
Podríamos definitivamente usar más,
no, necesitamos desesperadamente más, luchadores compasivos
y científicos e ingenieros enfocados al público
que se esforzarán para hacer lo correcto,
y no ser fáciles de manejar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)